okay so let's get into the biosin of it
all i was wondering when you first
started working on the trilogy day one
was the plan always to
pave the way to incorporating biosin or
was that an idea that came up along the
way uh the plan was to pave the way and
uh very specifically to dodson and i was
really fascinated by the idea of
uh someone who was pretty low down in
jurassic park on the ladder from a
corporate standpoint like he's the guy
that you send out with a briefcase uh
you know to costa rica and now you know
he has slowly worked his way up probably
through making a lot of uh you know
pretty shady decisions over the past 30
years and seeing how somebody can you
know apply that kind of ruthlessness uh
and and disregard for consequences uh to
something that has as much power as a
global corporation like biosin uh i was
i always wanted to try and get there
i have a lot of questions about
connecting the dots there first for the
for the company itself because you know
as a book reader i kind of can't help
but wonder you know just for your own
film franchise head canon have you ever
imagined how biosin kind of got back
into the dinosaur game is it you know
something that happened after the fall
of jurassic world and they kind of you
know like worked with what was left over
from that or was it something that was
in the works for earlier than that i
this is just how i see it like we don't
define it as clearly in the movies but i
i always saw it as the fall of jurassic
world was an opportunity uh for them and
uh the combination of being able to you
know secure the rights to get the
animals from sorna which we mentioned
that they do uh to be able to take is
you know the animals that uh are now
not only being created very at various
points across the globe but have escaped
and all of those embryos everything that
got out uh that they've been able to
come up with in a lot of ways a really
justifiable reason an excuse to lay out
to all these different governments are
these dinosaurs a problem for you bring
them over here like we're going to give
them a safe space we're going to give
them shelter and you know we don't have
to talk about any other kind of you know
experience we may be running because you
know no one has to know about that this
will tea is a question i'm going to
include towards the end but where do you
see manticore
fitting in in terms of like the genetics
companies at play in this in this
franchise that will be answered in
season 5 of camp cretaceous we have an
answer uh and there are there is an
element of this movie that and you may
recognize already if you've been
watching the show
uh but you know i don't think we
necessarily maybe do it in the way
people might expect we do it but uh you
know i think our movies tend to be
grounded in you know in a hopefully a
reality that that all of us can feel is
is tangible and relatable to the world
we live in uh and we try to you know
take what's going on the animated show
and connect it in a way uh that
hopefully doesn't invade too much you
know on our dominion story i'm all over
the place with my order here but now i
got to continue on camp cretaceous so
like one viewing i'm sure i might have
missed something but is there is there
another easter egg in addition to the
barbasol can
uh in this movie yeah are we talking
about cam quotations and cretaceous yeah
they revealed the the barbasol can in
the uh in the trailer
yeah they didn't reveal who's holding it
yes
so we'll see
i want to see that here's one other camp
cretaceous burning question i have for
you
is either of the ankylosaurus that we
see in this movie bumpy
oh uh in this movie i would like to
believe that yeah uh i you know i i care
about bumpy very much i think it's one
of the most adorable things that's ever
come out of this franchise uh and you
know i mean i'll say this i feel like so
much of this movie is about
i think our desire as an audience
for these dinosaurs to find peace and to
find a home it's this has been about
animals that have been displaced and now
we want them uh to to find a home we
want our characters to find redemption
and i think that's something that i'm
honestly i'm really
feel really good about the these three
movies and that i think we've we've
allowed us to care for these dinosaurs
like they're
characters and animals that we know uh
and you know if i was still a kid that's
something i would definitely have a
bumpy i kind of do now i mean yeah i i
obviously probably own too much jurassic
stuff and most of it's dinosaur so the
attachment to the dinosaurs themselves
in addition to the human characters it's
a big reason why this is one of my
favorite film franchises out there back
to uh dodgson though because you really
get a lot of creative opportunity here
given the fact that we do only see him
in one scene of the original jurassic
park movie so can you kind of walk us
through some of the creative
conversations you had with campbell
scott in terms of you know determining
what his life was like between movies
and and also figuring out which quirks
to include because he's got a very
unique personality there he does well
campbell is an incredible actor and i
couldn't you know i i first saw him uh
you know
probably dead again was that for when i
was in eighth grade and and then you
know big night and there's so many
movies i've just always been a a massive
fan and so to be able to have him come
in and then just give him
the room uh to to create the character
that he did and
he you know we did some writing together
and he did rework some of his lines to
make this guy be kind of delightfully
off uh in a way that only campbell could
could uh find and you can imagine
there's several other actors that could
have played that part and they all would
have been very different and he wanted
to dial into like how does somebody who
obviously is highly intelligent but
doesn't necessarily relate to people you
know in a way that uh
you know would probably allow him to
have too many friends
that end up you know being you know
someone who's seen seemingly an icon to
the whole world and someone that you
would trust but also be somewhat
distrustful of at the same time
his job very well done in that
department i was fascinated by him all
right this next question is just me
being greedy considering how many
original characters we got in this movie
i mean we got the big three after all
but if you had the opportunity to
incorporate one more character from the
original trilogy of these films who
would you pick and why god that's a
really good question i i would love you
know
ian malcolm mentions that he now has
several children uh he always mentions
you know uh
that he is kind of this family man you
know on the other side of this character
so his daughter uh you know from lost
world uh is is someone who if i'd found
some way uh i definitely would have done
it i we did acknowledge her in the movie
he does have a line you know
acknowledging that uh that she's out
there and very important to him so
that's something that mattered to me
that answer made my day that's what i
was hoping you were going to say all
right just to get into the ending a
little and again we'll save this for
later market spoilers and all that but
you know one thing that's always
fascinated me about the franchise and
kept me invested and kept the story
going is the fact that like mankind
keeps making the same damn mistakes over
and over and over so given the fact that
this is technically the conclusion of
your trilogy of films are you walking
away from it with
hope that mankind will learn from the
events of this film and this finally
will be a turning point or is that not
even possible
i honestly don't know like i i don't
know if i'm
if i'm arrogant enough to believe that i
could change the way people feel and
with a movie but what we can do uh is
is make sure that we're telling a story
that feels grounded in
science as we know it today and the
ecological balance of the planet which
is is struggling at this moment as as
you know species are disappearing and
and there's there's
there's not just you know climate change
is not just you know storms and things
getting hotter uh it is the whole uh
ecological balance of the planet being
disrupted and so to show how us
wielding genetic power uh in a way that
is irresponsible could lead to something
that could threaten the whole planet was
really important for us to do in this
movie and specifically to do it in the
context of ellie sattler her job as a
paleobotanist and how what she does and
studying ancient plants and how we can
potentially protect modern humans uh
with that knowledge that was what emily
and i went into right away wanted to
make sure we did it's not just about
dinosaurs running around eating people i
could keep you here all day but i'm not
allowed they're kicking me out thank you
so much for your time today and huge
congratulations and thanks for giving
keeping one of my favorite franchises of
all time alive and thriving i'm trying